welcome to this video what is this mr.
Boris mr. Boris okay i got a request to
play the l a-- kind and why laughs here
we go um form you're probably also a
moose not sure what black hair black is
doing against that that's just develop
and wonder if you can place you form
this is very similar to the four points
of course okay let's say take the center
directly this cannot be too bad you
cannot play d5 now and frankly speaking
isn't this just good for black know how
does he how does he maintain the center
yeah looks like the center so hopes
centers is very shaky Bishop to e7 maybe
I just come just should be self not
spent not spent ages him I could I could
just take it I guess okay he's some
probably intending to take take on at
five
I don't mind that really but but I need
to increase the pressure on you five
quickly the spawn is really weak and I
should win it
Jim
I guess he needs to make a pawn sec all
of this I'm sure how exactly but wow
really running into this with the temple
oops come on okay so he's attacking this
one okay keep it simple win the porn
what no
yeah just just take it should be should
be ok so the bishop and the long maybe
we should be 595 maybe add some maybe I
could consider to take what that's very
hard to believe you can now move pieces
multiple times still ok let's get onto
the c4 c5 I can check it ya know I can
take here I can just take it due to rook
c8 at the end
now it takes Knight takes bishop takes
rook c8 and I'm getting it back with
interest
also Bishop takes this is the same at
the a drugs yet don't really see a move
here for him I also threaten Bishop e2
grabbing the whole Queen side this is
why I was surprised at long castles it
just exposes the king and and a lot it's
a really substantial so it's two pawns
maybe Scott or creed ii 7am property
seven ok let's go with that
MC seven
yeah yeah I am this wasn't ideal really
not it but I keep I keep a big edge
anyway look on the seven phantom still
an attack wow this is no threat really
check check wow this is just like
resigns yeah this was a very sudden end
to this game I mean quite quite
surprising yeah around here i think im
just winning I mean he really doesn't
have a good move here just grabbing up
grabbing material here but but now I
need to do something else this was
probably ok but now I need to do
something of this a 5 was a bit
premature maybe maybe lookie age or
something yeah Roxy it I Roxy eight is
better here maybe habit but I'm still
keeping a big edge here I mean he must
prevent rugby too but it's not it's it's
not not easy to do so after this I'm
just I'm just improving securing the
back rank and and attacking cannot move
a 4 copies on minor three just when yeah
i think if then he really he really a
butchered up the opening already I'm not
I'm not sure about all this but i don't
know i don't like that at all think very
shaky position already yeah there's no
way to keep the point that it basically
losses upon and hear how she has also 95
which is a strong maybe even stronger
but ok it's it's just just material up
alright thanks for watching